good pitching matchup you've got you say
kikuchi coming off
maybe his best performance of his career
took a no hitter into the seventh inning
ended up giving up just one hit against
houston
he was terrific papa
murph taking a look he's got room it's
coming back to him
that's a big first out here's the
three-nothing pitch fastball is way high
and outside for ball four so mancini
with a two-out walk
on four pitches here in the top of the
first steady that'll bring up catcher
pedro severino severino banning 247.
chopper easy play for cacucci
terrific start really well done
the left-hander john means what he's
done on the year john means out of
olathe kansas former 11th round pick
back in 2014
by the orioles out of west virginia he
was outstanding his last time out
against oakland
seven innings pitched three hits he gave
up two runs punched out nine the two
runs he gave up were both solo home runs
and means quickly had two strikes well
hanukkah leads the mariners just about
in every offensive category
the feeble swing there as he got in on
the hands
one down there he is wearing out the
inside part of the plate
here's ty france 3-2 to france
and he gets some back-to-back strikeouts
to start the day
for john means he throws 93 miles an
hour right by ty france so back-to-back
punch-outs
lewis three-run homer game breathing
room
bounced down to first mont castle steps
on the bag and there go the mariners
brock open against gucci here in the
second no score
there's a base hit franco just over the
glove of
the leaping crawford yeah he didn't get
all of it but he got enough of it
team arkansas everett modesto arkansas
here's the pitch swung on ground ball
wide of third back headed by crawford
the throw to second and they're gonna
get the lead runner franco at second
base on a fine play by jp
crawford way to his right and mount
castle
is safe at first base on a six-four
fielder's choice
so mont castle now in scoring position
at second a.j stewart
checks in and bounced into the hole in
the left field
mount castle heading to the plate here
comes the throw and he's in
and the orioles take a one-nothing lead
b.j stewart
found the right spot crawford got over
got a glove on it but wasn't in a good
position to
make a strong throw home as he had to
get back on his feet and love to sin by
tony mancelino the orioles third base
coach right and this is
ramon 159 homer three driven in
maria's line drive base hit into left
field
stewart's coming home here comes the
throw
and he's in throw to second ureas
is out at second but it's a base hit rbi
stewart comes around to score
maria's with an rbi and the orioles go
on top two nothing
high first round draft pick out of the
small d1 school mercer
not many people knew about him but the
mariners did they selected him
fine drive right to franco at third
and lewis retired so one down and here's
catcher tom murphy
popped him up maria's
waiting two down two outs last of the
second orioles two mariners nothing
for white the pitch good night everybody
yeah
evan white called out strike number
three
third strikeout for john means the
marvelous mr means goes to work
in the third the 1-1 to moore and this
one's in the air to center field in his
traxxas mullins he's there
and he puts it away for out number one
sam hagerty steps in
1-2 breaking ball gets away from
severino
and hagerty is going to be the first to
reach on a strikeout and now the number
nine hitter jp
crawford a left-handed batter will stand
in against means
hagerty running the throw it's a dandy
and severino has his first caught
stealing
of the year gunned it down there right
on the money and watch this
fake bun attempt comes up squares his
shoulder and i mean you can't throw it
any better than that there we go tap the
fourth
idris severino
by devin idyllmore gilmore with the
assist there
like al franco the third baseman though
swinging another ground ball to moore on
the other side of the bag he's got it
throws the first in time to get franco
another 4-3 put out or two away from
baltimore here in the top half of the
fourth
got him one two three inning nice and
crisp
the left-handed bat of kyle seeger digs
in against me
and he gets him one two three go the
mariners in the fourth inning
means is cooking of the order that did
did the damage here's the leica here's
the pitch on the way swinging a ground
ball wide of third and into left field a
base hit for valencia so one on for
baltimore
one and two here looking for double play
the strikeout that works as well third k
swang and a miss struck him out
four strikeouts for cacucci struck out
three of the last four men that he's
faced four strikeouts on the way here's
the pitch of the way
swing and a miss by mullins for strike
three and make it five strikeouts he
ends up striking out the side
is that back with dylan moore as he
leads things off may not catch your
pitch but i'll play all the others
and he did last year wow there's the
change up
down he goes strikeout number seven for
means jp crawford flew out to the right
fielder is only at bat
little flare into center field mullins
coming hard and makes the sliding catch
pathfilenko base hit his last at-bat
big swing there hit well down the line
and it is a fair ball home run
pat valeka bangs it out first home run
of the year
and that one got out in a hurry ben pat
the bat
valencia orioles looking for some
insurance you talk about get off the bat
how about 109 miles an hour 367
feet home half of the seventh top of the
order for the mariners against john
means
2-2 and he's out of there kaniger called
out looking
and strikeout number eight he got him
with the change up
two outs in the seventh and on a day
where we learned about the passing of
one of the all-time great pitching
coaches in orioles history ray miller
whose mantra was very simple work fast
change speeds and throw strikes
john means living that today he has put
on a clinic so far today
seeger bounced to the right side mount
castle will take it himself
mariner's retired in the seventh friends
call call your friends call your
neighbors john means has something
special going
yeah now with one out the orioles have
runners on it first and second
back-to-back singles by mullins and
hayes and that'll bring up designated
hitter trey mancini
owens with his lead off second that's it
well
down the left field line way back it is
gone
trey mancini up over the scoreboard a
three-run
shot and the orioles have opened up a
six-nothing lead
there you go runners in scoring position
trey mancini doing his thing
boom boom the orioles now lead six to
nothing john means has yet to give up a
hit here's the pitch on the way to kyle
lewis
deep left field back and making the grab
is austin hayes with a big smile on his
face
oh take a breath one out of the eighth
inning 3-2 pitch got him on a chain jump
he strikes out murphy so give john means
now 10 strikeouts in the game one two to
white
and he gets him strikeout number 11.
eight innings no hits allowed and john
means
trying to write some oriole history
dylan moore at the plate for the
mariners 2-2 popped up
ruiz right there one down
so here's number zero sam hagerty here
comes the 2-2
swing and a miss one out away for john
means as he picks up the strikeout of
sam hagerty
john means he is tasting it now one out
away
and jp crawford stepping up to the back
first pitch swinging line drive he's
done it john means
enjoys the elite ranks of orioles
pitchers who have thrown a no hitter
it is the first individual no hitter
since jim palmer in 1969
the first overall no hitter since 1991
in oakland
and today a day that john means will
never forget
cinco de mayo a no-hitter for means
as the orioles come rushing out of the
dugout out of the bullpen
hugs all around means has done it he has
thrown a
no hitter against the seattle mariners